thrilled to have here on the program I
could spend the entire time that would I
have with this man by introducing him
but he's the chairman of Vayner X the
active CEO of vaynermedia you follow him
on Instagram and Twitter at garyvee the
best selling offer he's the sales wine
he's got a burgeoning sports agent in
business Gary Vaynerchuk good to see you
here sir thanks rich what's going on in
your life right now
well the NFL draft got me super hyped
okay cuz you are representing Tyree
Jackson yes Marcus Lodge okay the
schedule is you know okay
exciting me your diehard jet fandom we
just saw you rocking your new Jets
jersey at WrestleMania and um what do
you know about the schedule what can you
tell me about the schedule that gets
released tonight wow that worked why do
you think you know I think I know that
the Jets and Browns play on Monday night
to start the season makes sense uh right
for that was the first Monday Night
Football game yes uh ever I think the
Jets and the Steelers play in that game
that's one of my core predictions okay
uh having unbell against the Steelers
that makes sense yep that's all I really
know okay but that makes sense for the
for the start of the season for the Jets
to have Odell back where he once
belonged yep the Browns everybody wants
to see what the what they look like the
Baker darn old narrative is something
that would be amazing for the NFL for 15
years that's true
as early as they can build that rivalry
this is second time they're already
playing Baker Mayfield basically broke
out of the Hugh Jackson box that he was
being placed in on Thursday night
football against the Jets I was there it
was devastating I'm still angry I'm
still angry
I left that stadium and you know all
those they had him one in the you know
four years or whatever you know let him
off the mat let him off the hook to use
the Dennis Green phrase yeah that was so
that a sports cards I'm gonna say here
now on a national stage I believe that
the culture of sneaker flipping is gonna
bleed into sports cards because these
kids can't get enough inventory with
sneakers I bought several hundred
giannis rookies PSA ten prism rookies in
August before the season there were 150
a pop they're now trading for 380
gambling spa
Spedding yeah the way that panini and
tops do things now there's gonna be a
$50,000 ion card to be had out of
opening a six dollar pack talking about
what do you mean well I don't think
people understand that sports cards are
about to become a cultural phenomenon
again and so I'm just putting it on the
record and media so I'm historically
correct it's already happened if you've
been watching the markets been moving
pretty aggressively for the last year be
three theories one sneaker flippers are
running out of inventory and you can go
buy like I am right now
thousands of Darren Fox rookie cards if
you believe he's a player you can't buy
a thousand you know pairs of sneakers
that are gonna flake like you can't get
enough inventory and so a lot of these
entrepreneurs that are in the sneaker
culture love sports and are gonna do the
sports card thing that's one - sports
gambling and betting in the background
you have looka playing right now as an
image right now there are five seven
$10,000 Luca cards selling not listed
selling on eBay and those cards were
pulled out of a $3 $4 pack of prism
basketball cards once people understand
that I think people gonna get their
gambling fixed set of opening cards I
don't think most people know that
there's a there's gonna be several ten
twenty thirty thousand dollar
Xion cards to be had out of four or five
dollar packs that's like a lottery
ticket
that's better than a lottery ticket
because there's other cards and third 43
year-olds forty eight year-olds that
grew up in the prime years of sports
cards now have five six seven eight nine
year olds yeah and the same reason toys
reboot every 30 years GI Joe strawberry
shortcake I believe that sports cards 87
to 93 was a cultural phenomenon and now
those people are gonna relive it so I'm
making the prediction here on the Rich
Eisen show that sports cards is an
incredible alternative investment for
the next three to five years EMI my kids
love their basketball coach what about
all the cards that I have garbage
garbage yeah one of those garbage
because there was too much supply not
enough demand right so you know I mean
look you maybe you were smart and bought
8687 Philly or basketball and that has
all the rookies
and that's an incredible set but what
most people have 87 tops baseball early
upper deck all that stuff for the most
part that is not strong what strong is
you know pre-1980 graded you know you
send to these companies yeah back at PSA
and then the new stuff like the one of
one giannis is that are like 10,000 like
I think LeBron rookies Kobe rookies
they're trading at about a thousand
apiece rated well right now are five
thousand dollar cards in three years so
I'm excited I'm glad I'm glad I'm
bringing it up here because I'll be
happy to look at this clip in three
years Gary Vaynerchuk here in the Rich
Eisen show so the Zion card will be
worth more when the Knicks don't get
them because Dolan's karmas so terrible
or whatever because I know you've heard
because you're a professional yes
Patrick Ewing yes one of the all-time
most underrated players of all time list
is a sports show let's listen I'm an
enormous Knicks fan this I'm also 43 I
lived through that golden era me too but
if you're a real hardcore basketball
knowledgeable fan what you also know is
John Starks and Anthony Mason and
Charles Barkley are overrated like
they're amazing they're the best but I
believe that Patrick Ewing is extremely
underrated because I don't think people
actually understand what he was
surrounded by I really believe that so
my favorite of all time mine to like
like I want Oakley to be my best friend
like you know unfortunately is best
friends with Michael Jordan which you
know breaks my brain but but right I
think they're very solid players like
really good players but not as good as
people think because they were so tough
and awesome and rad and I believe that
Patrick Ewing is one of the all-time
underrated players because of the
context of what surrounded him he's
employed in a great airforce enters with
David Robinson and Hakeem Olajuwon well
I mean but early she's better than David
Robinson like he just is David Robinson
a hundred percent I mean that I'm I'm
shocked that people don't understand
that I mean it I just think he's way
better he just didn't he just that's
your Nick fan behind I really don't
think like I I really honestly I mean
this look I didn't say Hakeem my Knicks
fandom is the next sentence he's better
than Hakeem Olajuwon
that's my Knicks fan
my nan Knicks fandom his Patrick Ewing
is better than David Robinson guys he
just is like I test I lived it I watched
a lot of them like like Robin said like
like I don't know he was a he was a
really really the animals agree nice
solid grace a real Bri player
Patrick he was better so you're saying
the fact that Patrick Ewing cuz I'm
trying to bring this all full circle is
the Patrick Ewing is real quick on David
Robinson the West was whack
it was the reverse rightly it was MVP of
the league I don't give a crap the MVP
of the league is not a variable that is
super exciting to debate it's a really
like that's a really you know this
you're too smart for that statement like
Michael Jordan I hate him with my whole
heart should have an MEP every year like
LeBron should be MEP every year they do
it on timing cadence like there's so
many variables like MEP is a joke coach
there should be Bella check every year
or it should have been Phil Jackson
every year is also what you remember
time overrated coach Bill Belichick men
want to talk about somebody I dislike
all-time Phil Jackson enough with Phil
Jackson show me one see Bill Belichick's
greatest thing that ever happened to
Bill I'll check was Matt Cassell the
greatest thing that ever happened to
Bill Belichick's career was Brady being
out for that year
the problem for Phil is show me it like
Larry Brown is a way better coach than
Phil Jackson it takes from Gary Vee I
can totally understand what you're
saying but you should be the one season
of data where he didn't have a top
single player in the league and then we
could have at least a conversation have
you noticed
you can't be judged when you had the
single best player in the league every
time in your entire career
could you give you notice Chris that
right Gary Vaynerchuk has gone on this
hot take role although I'm not saying
that you don't believe it ever since I
brought up how Dolan's car
getting to the Knicks because the
ping-pong balls weren't bouncing as well
you started with Ewing I think that you
including their Ewing viewing is gonna
bring it home it's gonna bring confident
bring Zion home
I'm confident earth moves up
aggressively in their draft
it's an MSG cunny guys when the Knicks
roll out Durant and Kyrie and Zion and
the defensive force known as Mitchell
Robinson and the evolution of Kevin Knox
as he matures guys Nirvana is coming to
the garden I am so excited for the next
decade of my life I cannot believe the
great joy that I am about to have I'm
still having a really hard time with you
thinking Patrick Ewing's better than
David Robinson no problem I understand
you could make this argument was never
higher than fifth in MVP voting I'm
gonna lose my mind you cannot use MVP as
a variable to a sports debate it is a
ludicrous data point is not okay MVP is
also welcome for most this is important
how old and I'm 38 38 38 yeah that's
like right on the cusp like look I test
matters rich actually help us here this
is the oldest statement statesman here
yes
do you believe that it's hard I really
believe this it's hard when you didn't
have I test like if we're really having
a conversation if we're really having a
fun debate not for stick I do believe
not having I test data is an issue like
if you don't have AI test data you I
don't know anything about Oscar Robbins
I test data I understand like I can't I
would love to know more about dr. J for
real I believe and then this is like
every debate right sure looks like
talking about Babe Ruth was a renewing
clown David Robinson one-on-one in their
career and for real for real like if you
I test their matchups I'm telling you he
was a better player on I test he just
was New York City I'm not you know I'm
right I know you know I'm right
I mean
David Robinson got Tim Duncan got Tim
Duncan he was nothing it was not even a
debate
it wasn't even debate I'm gonna let you
guys get a pass no no I do remember
again Ewing Ewing just I just told you
John Starks
Charles Oakley and Anthony Mason are
grossly overrated let's start with that
on your it's hard for you to stand on a
Knicks Homer when I just sat here and
said three all-time emotional Knicks are
overrated I said that and you come back
at me and saying but they're not
considered great Knicks of all time
Charles Oakley is viewed as he's not on
the Mount Rushmore and he's viewed as an
all-time great Nick in my mind okay just
we do need to we do need to just
remember some of this stuff and I will
say this as a Knick fan before James
Dolan beat it out of me okay that
Charles Smith was viewed as the great
final piece for him the X Man was one of
them to Xavier McDaniel Charles Smith
Neil in Houston that was later but he
was viewed as somebody that was a savior
to the Knicks I'm talking about people
that were saviors in there but in terms
of the Ewing era he didn't have those
pieces he didn't have he didn't have his
Pippen he didn't have his Duncan David
Robertson was lucky enough to getting in
his life he didn't win that championship
let's just be very honest here if you
think David Robinson has a ring you also
think BJ Armstrong has rings you you're
really gonna quit we can have this what
I'm saying let me start over there's a
singular person that wins a ring in my
Gary Vaynerchuk one of one mine in the
NBA there's a singular person and so
David Robinson has zero rings in my mind
he was not the reason they won that
championship not by any stretch of the
imagination that was also towards the
end of his career though I'm
let's talk about but David Robinson's
zero NBA Finals appearances in his
career prior to date Tim Duncan putting
him on his damn that's only made it
because Jordan went to play baseball
because David Stern kicked him out for
games Patrick Ewing and the Knicks were
in the West they would have went to four
damn NBA Finals so let's talk real talk
not bolt 19 on Twitter and Instagram
quiet about a lot of stuff because I get
hot on stuff like this when you live the
eye test of watching that like that's
the key and I don't know where you're
watching this first games that are
watching were the playoff games where
David Robinson was absolutely doing
nothing against Shawn Kemp doing nothing
against Carl Malone doing nothing
against Charles Barkley those were games
I watch here's the fun part
and this is like Hall of Famer the
Admiral yeah yeah not the best human
ever like if I can't wait to see David
like like any time at all time Patrick
James a better NBA player than David
Ross
I do want to bring this up but now
otherwise we could go we could go on and
on on the subject I need an extra
segment but I do I do want to I do want
to bring this up with you before before
you go because we talk pop culture here
Nipsey Hussle yeah you got to know him
Jesus you really really changed my I
mean but one of those things where you
know you look you you've got fifteen
different sides to you different ways
that I could go in a conversation but I
did want to bring this up and I know
that kind of brings it down oh that's
okay god I know you you love this guy
this guy how did you meet him we met him
in his studio when he was working on the
album that you know that he put out his
camp my camp had a lot of good vibes
towards each other and we went to the
studio and spent an hour together and
that started we just you know by the way
this is fun to say you and I hit it off
immediately yes sometimes you just smell
right sometimes you meet somebody and
you just know that you're gonna know
them for the rest of your life okay
and we really connected man he was a
really thoughtful kid trying to do a lot
of good in his way I think
the thing I'm most passionate about is
for all my shtick and style if you
listen to what I'm saying there's some
real tried and true love and good and
positivity and I really uh he had a real
message he was a really hard worker he
was a long-term you know I think in 50
year terms he did as well like some of
the stuff we would talk about there's a
video of him and I at the NBA all-star
weekend we had dinner at NBA all-star
not too long ago obviously and as soon
as he walks in I'd say to all my friends
are like get ready some for some really
deep philosophical talk you know nipsey
the cool rapper wait to hear what we're
actually about to talk about it was very
thoughtful he was a warm heart he was a
good dude like and I bet you for
everybody listening and I'm sure for a
lot of people here who didn't closely
follow him I what probably makes me feel
best is when this devastating thing
happened I think anybody outside the
circle of knowing him really really well
were flabbergasted by how the collective
culture so reacted he wasn't as big as
POC and Biggie in the macro when this
happened but I think what affected a lot
of people that had either never heard of
him or maybe heard of him once or twice
was like well why are like the biggest
names in the in the game so still I mean
I'm getting goose but still three weeks
later posting so emotionally it was cuz
if you actually had the luxury to even
know him a little bit he impacted you
immediately he was a special guy that's
why I wanted to bring him up I'm glad he
did because you know of
people that I know you're the one that
I've I knew that you knew him yeah you
know that's why I wanted to bring it he
did certainly here in Los Angeles where
obviously he's a great sports fan so
much I mean he was he was at the I think
he was at the sweet 16 games and down in
Anaheim was those weekend he passed I
mean he was a specialty they're talking
about maybe putting a banner in Staples
I heard that yeah did you hear that
conversation yeah rosh mark Ozzy wrote
about that if you know if you knew I'm
sure you guys saw from a sports
standpoint like a lot of the players
around the league's reactions there's
that Durant curry clip like in the
streets in the culture
like he meant so much he was doing so
much good he was trying so hard in his
way to do such a real thing he was a
really special dude David Robinson yeah
switchback Gary Vaynerchuk follow him
like the rest of the free world on
Instagram and on Twitter at Gary Vee
Gary Vee there's no other segment
there's one other one we're gonna do you
nice to talk Jets a little bit I got
things to say this Robinson Ewing thing
threw me off this is good this is gonna
be on our appetizing over time this next
conversation Colin Hanks still to come
here on this program bump him I got
things to say for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app